[Music]  hi i am abhishek sandhi from stl and i  am delighted to be at ftdh berlin  the past nine months have shown us the  impact high speed optical connectivity  has on our lives through hundreds of  applications  i believe that the technology landscape  is going to change dramatically over the  next two decades  as applications will become even more  immersive in user experience  with 3d projection it wouldn't be a long  shot to imagine  being on a lion safari in africa or  being part of an action thriller while  sitting in your living room  the possibilities are endless and  limited only by our imagination  newer lighter cloud-based networks will  make it easier to serve  underserved areas of the globe and help  in making the world a more equal place  the mantra to achieving all this is  innovation and i just hope  that the pace with which we innovate  just keeps going up